hey what is up welcome to another
episode of get close and we have one of
my favorites back again
tim
back on get close gc baby hey
i am your host geo uh bart
and since this is tim's second
appearance on our podcast this is
deuces dos
[ __ ] i that's all i had um we're gonna
do though no it wasn't even that good uh
we're gonna do this podcast different
than the first one all right so in the
second episode um
i surveyed my fans and i asked them to
submit their questions so get it
ask me the rawest questions you got oh
[ __ ] i mean they're not very nah give me
that give me that raw all right let's
start with some raw
what's the perfect way to eat ass
this is what they want to know uh the
perfect way to eat ass is right out the
shower and that's the only way to eat
ass
that's true
have you ever had any encounters where
it wasn't right out of the shower nah i
mean look i always say this right i joke
about eating ass a lot um
i always just say you know don't eat ass
unless it's someone you like really love
um why i'm not white for hepatitis i'm
not i'm just not a casual ass eater no i
mean either um i think it's just kind of
something like
you know butt stuff wasn't my uh my fa
like i was never like oh buttholes you
know what i'm saying like a lot of
people are i feel
uh a lot of people yeah people are
really in the butt stuff especially like
you know i can't even watch like when
i'm watching like porn and
um
you know
there's like a couple going in
if i see
like if i'm like scrubbing through it
and then i see like eventually it ends
up in her butt i'm like nope x out can't
do it
not a fan of this yeah um what it's just
just the whole thing or what it
represents the whole thing
no it says i i've never i've just never
really been here's the thing i poop so
much right yeah that's why i just always
associate buttholes with poop and like
i just i can't you know and i and i've
heard you know girls say that like you
know the anal gives them like a stronger
orgasm
and you know shan budram will tell you
that the man's g-spot is up his butt but
yeah i just can't get into it um she
likes to
deliver trickery though
i don't know i don't want her to [ __ ]
try to cast a spell on me and make me
expose my butthole
oh george shannon
john's crazy shannon
shannon's always trying to convince
dudes to you know like oh you should try
you should try some anal stuff so you
ever put a penis in your mouth it's
really good
hey don't knock it until you try it we
talk about you crazy
it's not for me but in terms of eating
ass it's like yeah you know like fresh
out the showers is the way to go what if
the person of the the acid you're eating
is super shy and every time you get
close like she just wiggles away like
get back here i would then we don't have
to do it i'm not like oh please let me
eat your ass you know what i'm saying
this is kind of like you know if it
happens i feel like i you know just the
past maybe like
later in life i was like oh that
butthole but that's a cute butthole yeah
yeah okay oh so then you warmed up to it
whereas before you were kind of like it
was all just jokey but yeah before i was
kind of joking before i would have never
you know eaten ass was just like a joke
and then i think it got really popular
the past few years was it the booty
grocery yeah oh you want to hear some
[ __ ] yeah janae aiko said in a radio
interview she doesn't even like it
she said it as a [ __ ] joke wow she
was like yeah when i she's like you know
what i actually don't even like it like
i just kind of said like yeah eat the
booty like groceries is funny
and so many people were like they've
they switched flip for them yes and she
lied to us i think she ate all of us a
lot of us tried eating ass because of
her saying whatever she was talking
about eating booty like eating booty
cheeks not the booty hole maybe is that
possible i don't think anyone does i
mean i've definitely bitten some cheeks
yeah but i don't think uh that was what
she was talking about yeah i don't think
they say that yeah no no uh yeah so
there is no perfect way i mean the
perfect way was just straight out of the
shower that's it enough story i think
that's the perfect way to stick your
tongue inside
no
not not hey let the gentleman answer it
oh my bad who knows i think i'm sure
there's people that do that what about
you i don't i don't do that should i
stay on the outside huh just the outer
rim
i see you don't get close at all you
don't want to get anywhere near the hole
uh
i mean i think the goal is the hole but
not in the hole oh okay
nice thank you i i i'm sure everyone
appreciates that answer
okay next question
what's up tim
uh i'm curious why you don't have any
tattoos i'll tell you why i don't have
any tattoos um when i was younger i
wanted so many tattoos like like a
tweety bird i wanted [ __ ] well a lot
of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] um when i was
super young i went all types of like
like you know like a [ __ ] dragon yeah
like well like i wanted like a japanese
style tiger because i was born in the
year the tiger which is next year 2022
six um and then uh microphone with the
cord wrap no not that stereotype
but i i did want like you know i'm a
pisces so i want like some koi fish and
like all types of [ __ ] right yeah um and
then as i got older i had this sick
tattoo idea bro it was gonna be like a
sketchy um sailboat that i either wanted
to get like here or like on my arm
because
i have this whole philosophy about like
because whenever people are like yo
um
how does it feel to be living your
dreams i always say like i don't look at
my goals as dreams i look at them as a
destination
and i always use them because i feel
like a destiny a dream is something
that's like
um like unattainable unattainable yes
yes and a destination you know it's
there yeah and as long as you keep going
you'll get there eventually and like
with a sailboat you know what i'm saying
when you're on the ocean the wind might
force you to adjust your route and
adjust your sails but if you keep going
you'll get there eventually right yeah
so i had this whole sailboat thing i
wanted why is it sketchy
and that is tight no no not sketchy as
in like weird sketchy isn't like
sketched oh yeah yeah yeah i thought
like the boat looks sketchy no no no
like it's like it's etched yeah i
thought it was uh i thought it was
sketchy like like it's been [ __ ] with
the black pearl no no no i mean that'd
be cool it kind of has a mind of its own
like you have your career in your dreams
but you also got to be flexible because
it might go where it wants to go yeah
that works too but i just mean like
not clean lines gotcha um and then but
as i got older i realized how wishy
washy of a person i was especially in
terms of like my outer appearance you
know what i'm saying like i changed my
hair a lot like even you know like i
don't know 10 years ago i would have
said i would never wear skinny jeans
ever and i just kind of felt like you
know my outside would change a lot yeah
and look at us look at you now dude
so i just i was like i don't want to get
a tattoo and and want to change it later
right um but i actually might oh oh and
also my dad was completely against
tattoos he was like what's what they all
say man they get over it what you
haven't showed your mom
uh i mean but she's what's she gonna do
now this is true you know and that's the
thing my dad was like so against it and
then just recently though we were
talking about it and he was like
ah whatever i was like what he was like
yeah i wouldn't mind you're such a good
son i just you are a good son he doesn't
ask a lot of me you feel me uh and uh
he's that's just one thing when i was
little he was like just don't get
tattoos don't get tattoos and but i've
always kind of like you know joked about
it and i don't know if he was watching a
vlog or what where i was saying yo the
main reason i don't get them is because
of my dad but just recently he was like
ah oh whatever
so and then we were joking around at
dinner and he was like i'll tell you
what
if i draw it for you you can get it oh
so i was like i saw i was like okay do
this right chantharangsu in thai i'll
and i'll get it tatted and so he wrote
it for me since
you're gonna get a tatted i think so
where are you gonna get it um probably
just you know some just like shoulder
like on the black on my back and then um
i
this would be sick if below it i could
get um because they have these
traditional thai tattoos that monks give
you those like
[Music]
if i could get that under it that'd be
tight that would go to thailand and get
it done that's the only way to do it
yeah legit your pops is cool man man i
wish he was so cool he's super cool i
wish your dad was like let me draw it
for you and then he went on to draw that
sketchy sailboat
and then you have to get it done and
it's all [ __ ] up well here's the thing
that a lot of people don't know my dad
was actually an art major
what yeah so draws hell is sick yeah
yeah painting drawing all that [ __ ] he's
actually there's a few growing up in the
house we grew up in in uh when paramount
there was a few of his like paintings
and stuff in the world yeah yeah does he
still paint now no
no he just he's just not in he just
doesn't yeah maybe that's where you got
your like creative stuff from huh i
think that's definitely a good and my
mom my mom also is like very artsy when
like
cooks and she's like you know like plays
music i think maybe that's why they were
so supportive of my uh non-traditional
journey it's so cool yeah no your dad's
really cool um because we were talking
about eating booty
right now yeah and then i remember the
video that you did with your dad where
he's asking you these questions there's
like a youtube video oh yeah yeah that i
did with the cut thick accent he's
talking about ass eating ass and he uses
that term he had a like a dad joke right
he had like a joke where he was like
he almost had sex
yeah no it was like we have sex almost
every night yeah how often do you and
mom have sex he was like almost every
day
saturday almost sunday almost so almost
every day
that was so funny i don't even know how
he i don't know if he heard that
somewhere or what but [ __ ] fire
[Laughter]
that is [ __ ] cute um okay another
question
tim would you ever be in a broadway show
there's a oh then they quote this
there's a bright golden haze and they
wrote oh
there's a bright golden haze on the
meadow
there's a bright golden haze on the
meadow
the corn is as high as an elephant's eye
and it looks like it's climbing clear up
to the sky
oh what a beautiful morning
oh what a beautiful day
i've got a beautiful feeling
everything's going my way it sounds
familiar it's from oklahoma the musical
oh then no i don't know that
i uh i did a lot of musicals in high
school and i sing that song all the time
on my socials and [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah so um
yeah i did musicals in high school um i
was in oklahoma i was in the little shop
of horrors
and yeah 100 i would love to uh do
broadway one day i think that would be
lit i actually um
i ever tell you guys that i i i got hit
up to audition for hamilton before i
knew what it was
no no not at all did you turn it down
let me tell you what happened so no so
this is before
hamilton was the mega beast that it is
currently right yeah and but it was
still popping on broadway i just had
never heard of it so i got an email from
hamilton hamiltoncasting and they were
like hi we would love for you to submit
for this part in hamilton
um it's a musical on broadway um it's a
hip-hop musical and i was like oh
interesting but at that point i was
really kind of like
writing like raps and [ __ ] and i had
intentions of working on a new album
right
and they were like and i know how much
time goes into a musical
and um so i think they were looking for
uh their traveling cast that would tour
for like la and [ __ ] like that and uh
and i just knew
just from even doing musicals in high
school like i don't have time for this
right how much time does it take it's a
lot because it's it's twice a day
sometimes and then there's like constant
rehearsals and so it's like it's like
every day you know what i'm saying so um
i i wrote back i was like thank you so
much for your offer um but i just i
don't think currently i would have time
to commit to a musical right and they
were like that's fine
and then i was on the phone with my my
agent at the time and uh i was actually
going to be in new york to to work on
something else right maybe while in out
i forget but she was like hey we should
get you some tickets to hamilton while
you're out there uh it's like the
biggest musical on broadway right now
like people wait for months to get
tickets and i was like
so
here's the funny thing
i was like
they
emailed me to audition and i said no and
she was like tim
what she was like
hit the back right now i was like oh my
god it's so stupid i mean in the back i
was like yo i'm so sorry um you know
what my schedule opened up i was like
yeah i was like i'm so dumb i would love
to audition and they were like sure
so they said just submit a video of you
singing a like a pop song and a broadway
song and then do some rapping did you do
oklahoma and then one of your originals
no actually saying i actually sang um
some in sync and then i sang which one
probably like
um
[Music]
maybe it was maybe it was tearing at my
heart maybe it was nice maybe it was bye
bye
yeah it was one of those yeah cause
those are the classics right yeah yeah
and then um
and then i sang i think like a whole new
world and then um and then i just
wrapped some of my own [ __ ] right and
they were like that's great um okay can
you send a follow-up audition now of you
rapping and singing
some of the songs from hamilton and
we're like they're like we're going to
send you sheet music to read from i'm
like [ __ ] i don't know how to read sheet
music right so they sent me the sheet
music aj raphael
he could have helped me he actually
auditioned too um and so i uh
he said they sent me the sheet music and
i didn't know how to read it and i was
like i'm just gonna listen to the actual
musical and learn the [ __ ]
and then i was like ugh i don't feel
like doing this and i just i just never
sent my follow-up audition um so who
knows if i would have got it or not but
um but i still think like i said in the
last podcast i think timing-wise it
still wasn't necessarily right for me
yeah yeah so
uh yeah so then you're saying that you
would do it because it would be super
lit i would totally do it also i really
annoyed lin-manuel miranda one night in
new york at a uh event
for his uh in the heights was like i was
at a special engagement for like they
were premiering the trailer for in the
heights and i was so hyped to meet like
lin-manuel that's why i was like i
really wanted to go so i'm at this event
and my dumb ass didn't realize it was a
more of a media event right not like a
um like a networking one not like a
networking one so
he's over here i'm waiting to take my
picture right i see him there in the
corner and i see all these people around
him [ __ ] asking him questions and i'm
like god these fans are [ __ ] annoying
oh like no they're there with their like
phones asking them these long ass
questions
like the
network around the microphone
yeah i was so dumb i was also kind of
turned because it was like an open a bar
event right and so they're over there
asking him these super long questions
and he's answering them and i'm like
this in the corner i'm like talking to
another girl who also wants a picture
i'm like
yeah if they don't keep asking them
these like life story questions
did it that loud yeah i was like talking
loud like being obnoxious because i i
wanted those people to chill but not
realizing this is like interview right
and so he did one of these he was like
he was talking to them and he was like
he did like he looked at me he's like
like eyes are like ugh and i was like i
was like oops i annoyed him i think oh
he was annoyed at you and annoyed at me
oh yeah and then so and then afterwards
i was able to kind of i was like alone
with him like i saw him chilling i was
like hey man just you know like seeing
hamilton like four times moana is my
[ __ ] and he was like oh you know thank
you thank you blah blah we took a
picture that was that hopefully he
doesn't remember
oh you you saw him at a different event
where you got to talk to him no it was
that same night why wouldn't he remember
i'm saying hopefully he doesn't remember
now who i am
so for when i auditioned for another one
of his things in the future
yeah he doesn't go that's that [ __ ]
kid oh my god
that's [ __ ] funny dude yeah what an
embarrassing story
um okay next question
how did you know chia was the one i'll
tell you this that's a good question
that is a good question people ask me
all the time um one of the ways
one of the ways i knew
that she was different
because i was kind of i wasn't
necessarily in the mindset of like uh
comparing cheetah you knew she's
different to how many to like with the
other 215
just women just different women that i
had dealt with how many though because
you don't see that i that i've like
dated
a handful
47 no
what big are your heads well i said i
say uh you know it's diff my smash
number is different from the people i
consider i was like talking to you know
what i'm saying and like
i definitely went went in during my my
year and a half of like
uh freedom you know what i'm saying
but we're not gonna talk about that that
means 50.
there's 50 stars on the freedom
[Laughter]
um but so i was you know i still kind of
like just
casually doing my thing and then when
when i first kind of interacted with
chia and like we hold up how did you
guys even meet i don't even think i know
this story sure i'll say that sorry yeah
so um
man 10 years ago uh because we've been
together for 10 years oh so this was 11
years ago oh my god because we've
officially been together for 10 years
wow oh i know why it feels long because
you guys are doing long distance yeah oh
wait you know what so if we've been
together for 10 years because we were
like casually kind of talking for a year
before that so that was 11 years ago so
we started talking so 12 years ago wow
12 years ago one of her friends one of
her good friends used to make youtube
videos okay and i was um i thought that
girl's videos were funny so me and that
girl used to um
like we followed each other on like you
know when you like someone's videos you
guys just kind of like end up being like
internet friends yeah so i followed her
on facebook and we're friends on myspace
all that [ __ ] and so one day i was like
it was like 2 am i think i was just
bored on my computer just scrolling
through people's facebooks right and i
was going through that girl's pictures
and i was like yo who is your sexy ass
friend aka
aka
she was asking my girl chia blah blah
blah and i was like all right well just
let you know
she's hot right just gonna put it out
there and then maybe like a couple
months later she's like hey we're we're
all taking a road trip to la i'd love to
like meet you um
maybe shoot a little video or something
like yeah cool so they uh they were on a
road trip and i said what's up and i'll
say you're gonna introduce me to cheers
she's like yeah come on and but she had
a boyfriend at the time and this is how
just not this is how like just tunnel
vision she is so like i was i legit like
i went up to her she's sitting in the
van i remember it so like clearly she's
like on her phone texting or whatever
and i was like hey tim nice to meet you
and she goes
hey
and it just went right back to her phone
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] i know
so
after lover so i was like okay all right
well there that is right but then after
the fact um i guess
like her friend told her like hey so you
know that guy like you know thinks
you're cute or whatever and she's like
oh but you know she wasn't gonna do
anything she had a boyfriend right so
then i want to say like two or three
months later i get a random ass message
from her on facebook and she's like hey
and i was like
interesting so i texted the mutual
friend i was like yo your girl just
messaged me and she was like oh she's
single now oh
yes i'm in there so um so then we kind
of just started chatting on facebook and
eventually started a bbm messaging you
know and then uh
a blackberry messenger oh okay and then
uh we started chat we were probably just
talking for like a year just the social
like just on you know texting and [ __ ]
romantic nights
it got very flirty and it got like
pretty romantic up until not exclusive
up until um i had a show
in toronto
and i was like yo um i'm gonna be
in canada and she had family in toronto
so um she was like oh yeah cool like
i'll go to your show
and then we just kind of like uh you
know then we kissed and we hit it off
and then um
and then so
the first time when we like uh when she
like we were like spending the night
together i remember i was like all right
well i'm gonna go like take a [ __ ] and
shower and this is this is when i knew
she was different all right i was like
i'm gonna take a [ __ ] and shower and she
was like okay and i was like
she's different
like the fact that she wasn't like she
didn't crack up and she also wasn't like
oh my god too much information you know
i was like she was just like very oh
cool you're gonna [ __ ] like yeah yeah
that's normally no big deal yeah dope
and i was like she's tight right and
then um
do you do that [ __ ] just to kind of put
feelers out with like people yes i'll
say just weird [ __ ] sometimes to see if
like is this person going to get my
sense of humor or not you know what i'm
saying and for her i was like i'm
shooting a shower and she's like okay
and i was like she's tight
[Laughter]
and then um
and i'll tell you what and here's and
and that was just kind of like really
surface level how i just thought she was
different you know because i texted rick
like that night i'm like man
i love this girl it's just like but
[ __ ] around gotcha okay yeah and then
so we were kind of um
not
like officially i was still flying back
and forth to canada um to see her but it
was like you know she knew i might have
been like seeing other people she was
she could see other people she wanted it
was kind of like we're just seeing
what's up right
and then it got to a point
where one day she was like hey um you
know what because she knew i was kind of
like just about that groupie life at the
time i was kind of messing around doing
my thing she was like you know what i
don't know if i want to do this anymore
she's like you can't you you got to
choose like either either you're seeing
me or you're messing with these groupies
right and i was like [ __ ] because i
wasn't mentally really ready to
commit yet right
and because you're saying you've had
just barely the one year because you
were in a yeah i was in like a four-year
relationship you know and then so
um
so and then
i was kind of like god damn i don't know
what i'm gonna do and then the next day
she hit me up again she was like you
know what
i take it back she was like i apologize
for even making giving you that
ultimatum and i was like i was like what
what happened and she's like you know
what i was thinking about it it's not
your fault we're long distance it's not
your fault you're fresh out of a
relationship
if i force you to do anything right now
it's just not going to work out because
you're going to feel like you're not
going to feel like you're ready so she's
like look just
do what you need to do and then let me
know like wow
and then and then i was like and she
kind of jedi mind tricked me because
immediately i was like not only was like
she's so level-headed i've never met a
girl who's this objective at looking at
things they're never like that
and i was right you tone it down over
there
but i was also like i need to lock this
girl down before she gets sick of my
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so um
probably [ __ ] around for another
couple months before i was like all
right
i was like all right all right be my
girlfriend sleep on it
and then i made her officially my
girlfriend and i was like 10 years ago
how did you make her your girlfriend
would you say were you like okay well go
steady well so you know how we were long
distance and i was always picking her up
from the airport so one day when she
landed
i had you know the signs that the guys
hold when they're like the chauffeur is
holding their last name i had the
flowers and i had a sign that said you
have the fingerless gloves too i had a
[ __ ] driver hat
and i just had a sign that said will you
be my girlfriend
where are there people seeing this and
going oh
probably oh you wouldn't even pay
attention i don't know
man that's awesome were you nervous a
little bit because you were like what
should you do did you say yes and kiss
you yeah that's awesome yeah how cute
and then we like smashed in front of the
whole airport because
everyone clapped
yes [ __ ] her yes
that's romantic i can't wait till veda
hears the story
now that's really beautiful man yeah i
mean like once you find that one
like everything just [ __ ] clicks you
know maybe one day i'll feel that
it's a good one
i got a good imagination
wow these are some high level burns
right now
oh yeah dude yeah all right next
question
uh when did you first feel like you were
famous
when did i first feel i was famous um
i started you know i started getting
recognized
on my like the college campus during the
youtube stuff um
what year is this you think this was
probably let's see first asian boy had
just dropped this had to be like
2008 2009-ish
and like i did a video i did that video
and i did a no racial which was kind of
getting me like a little skit i did with
rick which was doing well too um
i don't know if i felt famous
yeah okay you know what i felt legit
like oh this is this is crazy
um i
i was like hey guys i'm gonna do a
little meet and greet
at uh in new york at uh at central park
or whatever whatever park i said i said
like meet me at this park right let's do
a little meet and greet cause you know
like youtubers used to do that [ __ ] back
there like hey guys listen i'm gonna be
here come come say what's up right yeah
and
and this was kind of like i guess i
didn't realize how popping my youtube
[ __ ] was at this point and then um i had
a meet and greet at this park and there
were so many people police like shut me
down they were like you can't do this
without a permit there's too many people
here and it was kind of wild and they
actually and so we went from one small
park which was bryant park to like
central park because that's way bigger
yeah and then so we went to central park
and then a bunch of the people still
followed me there and there's one point
where like i'm like all right y'all i
didn't know what to do at that point so
they just kind of sat and i [ __ ] felt
like i was like jesus like preaching to
the to the crowd and then it ended up
being like so many people like the
police actually escorted me out because
it was like wow we need to get you out
of here and i was like oh [ __ ] this is
kind of crazy like how many people would
you say like 500 a thousand i wouldn't
say all that but it was definitely like
enough to be like oh this is a little
over like a little overwhelming cause of
commercial yeah yeah um that's amazing
so that was a cool moment it was cool
vlog for sure
i don't think that many people show up
now but
you never know man yeah who knows i mean
never but i would never do a free meet
and greet nowadays
what do i look like a [ __ ] amateur
youtuber
[Laughter]
doing something if i was doing that now
like such like just attention hungry you
know yeah it is it would be weird now
for sure
hey i'm at disneyland come join me
that's weird that's so funny that we
used to do [ __ ] like that yeah like hey
i'm gonna go be at magic mountain let's
all go [ __ ] ride rides together yeah
fine i would never know
now i'm at disneyland with my [ __ ]
hat sunglasses mask
and they still recognize you they still
find you well because i'm either next to
rick or chia yeah
same yeah
all right that was [ __ ] funny um is
there a reason and i'm sure that i i
already know this reason is there a
reason you got rid of your dope stage
name yeah i put out a whole [ __ ]
eight-minute video about it and you
watch it dude where can they find it on
youtube
[Laughter]
uh but a long long video short
it had a lot to do with um you know i
was i was sitting in my room like in my
house like pandemic time
and i i had been thinking about it for a
couple years right
but then i was like ah i'm already
everything's already branded as tim with
the daily ghetto like why would i change
it
um
and then i was like
contemplating pandemic time i was like
wow [ __ ] this is such a weird time like
anybody could just die right like like
death is so like weird right now have
you thinking about death and i was like
if i died today
um would i want
to be remembered by this like youtube
name i can't wait
man like i don't want i didn't want to
be remembered as like yeah because when
i first made up timothy de la ghetto it
was i was literally just freestyling in
a video and i was like oh that sounds
catchy because i love the fresh prince
right yeah but then when i really
thought about where i wanted to go in my
career right tv movies all that [ __ ]
accepting awards i didn't want to be
accepting my wards as my [ __ ] youtube
name right and i also thought like if i
die today i want to leave a legacy of
like you know my whole mo is to make
asian people proud yeah part of the
language part of their culture and you
know such a big thing for thai people is
like we have these really long last
names and i'm like
originally i used to think oh if i want
to make it in hollywood i can't use my
real last name that's too long yeah i'm
saying i need to come up with something
more uh that's just shorter it's shorter
shorter and catchier right so i'm like
that's why that's another reason why i
felt like i needed a stage name but i'm
like no [ __ ] that if i want to be at the
point where i see myself then they're
gonna have to be able to say my name you
know yeah like schwarzenegger or you
know what i'm saying like prince could
become a [ __ ] symbol yeah or nicole
singer you know what i'm sure
so i'm like okay let me let me kind of
let me let me do this and even though i
started off
to be the asian fresh prince
i was like maybe let me not build my
legacy off
being
the asian something and let me just be
tim chantarang
and like embrace who i am and like my
last name and kind of like rep for my
dad and my thai people as well
and also
there's the issue of like the younger
woke fans who don't know it's from the
fresh prince are like
are like oh like oh why are you taking
like the ghetto and like uh
appropriating the ghetto and using this
to try and come up like that whole video
why not watch the episode and that's the
thing it's like i got so sick of like
making that point and explaining it um
that i was like you know what i've been
wanting to change it already i was like
[ __ ] it let me just do it yeah you know
make it easier and because like if you
want to make that point like yeah i did
grow up in like a like a part of long
beach that people would consider ghetto
but also that but that wasn't even the
reasoning behind the name so i was like
man [ __ ] it um
yeah it was really dope uh i was looking
up some of your information because
you're going to be here and i wanted to
make sure i got everything right yeah so
i i searched tim and then i wrote
delegate and then like your last name
popped up and i'm like that's tight that
is tight it was really
[Laughter]
i remember when i first found out ac
slater's last name wasn't slater i was
crying
crying yeah because he had like some
story about like how he his dad joined
like the army or something and got
discriminated against uh so it was like
sanchez or santos oh you mean the actual
character yeah yeah
[Laughter]
no in the show yeah yeah like you were a
lonely one that's why his dad changed it
to slater that's right got it and i was
like it was supposed to be ac sanchez
[Laughter]
no i love that i [ __ ] love that you
like to took took uh ownership of it for
sure yeah man i'm like if i wanna if i
will because my whole thing is like you
know i want to make my asian people
proud you know make asian kids feel like
they shouldn't be ashamed um because i
remember being a little kid and like if
my parents called me on on the phone i'd
be like talking quietly because i didn't
want people to hear me speaking thai and
like make fun of me or whatever yeah but
then like i was like man [ __ ] that
that's stupid you know so that's why i
like i would always in my vlogs i make
sure and speak thai
um because i want people to hear it and
make like kids that are growing up be
like oh i shouldn't be
that yeah you know and especially if i
have this long ass dope thai last name
i'm like [ __ ] man let me start using
this [ __ ] you know yeah
maybe i will add the daylight in there
it's [ __ ] funny
okay uh what's what this is what what's
his secret to getting hot babes
your secret what's your secret dude oh
man i had to ask what's your secret
sauce that's so funny man all those
babies are so hot i love how like
it it's it's such a simple answer that a
lot of people just don't want to take in
you know yeah that they're like it it
has to be a mystery it has to be this
like [ __ ] secret right secret it's so
silly i always tell him like just go
talk to him bro like that's really like
okay talk to him no but you gotta go
past that because i know [ __ ] weird i
know it's true okay look not gonna lie
um
being funny helps a lot yeah um
i i i feel like 90
of my
poon that i've acquired
is i can
thank my prone acquisitions my pun
acquisitions
are because of the jokes i always tell
people look i'm not the type of guy if i
walk into a party a girl's like man i
want to [ __ ] that guy right but i'm like
give me 10 minutes next to the [ __ ]
cheetos and they're like i might suck
this guy's dick
because i'm charmed i laugh that is your
secret recipe yeah and uh so being funny
helps but at the end of the day i think
um
i think a lot of
a lot of guys just you know like when
you when you're like oh man what's the
secret to eating hot babes it's just so
like you've been calling them hot babies
it's so just cringe you know it's i
think a lot of guys just sounds like
you're trying to trap a beaver on the
board
what is the secret that is what they're
doing though a baby like what do you got
to put on the fishing street yeah they
bite because they're not biting what i
have it's so silly i mean yeah they look
at it like like that right yeah um and i
think it's so dumb when dudes are like
man like
oh man how do i how do you get a girl
how do you get that girl it's like out
of your league you know what i'm saying
and i was like man bro there's there's
no lead there's no leagues man i feel
like once you once you tell yourself
that it's like you're going into the
game saying you already lost you know
what i'm saying which is just
you're knocking yourself down which
already like that means your confidence
isn't up because confidence is key too
just going into it
is the number one it's the number one
thing yeah because like if you walk into
a room like you're the [ __ ] people like
oh this guy's the [ __ ] you know and i
think i think i mean you're you're a
woman yeah sometimes i think
and i think a lot of women will say like
confidence is so 100 yeah it's like so
attractive like you're shorter than me
right this is true uh yep uh but your
confidence everyone is
all right dude the dude in the [ __ ]
far corner is pissing me off
like keep stating the obvious
but your confidence i never remember
that you're shorter than me um you know
what i mean like i just always feel like
you have such a big presence that's
funny that you say that because there
are there are people that are like the
same height as me and um but then like i
i've brought i mean conversation with
somebody i was like you know i'm you
know like we're like i'm the same height
as that guy they're like what
no
because because of what you said yeah
what i'm saying and i remember even like
and i don't know i mean and and then
kids will ask me like
how do you become so confident and i
don't really know how to answer that i
think you have to love yourself that's
so that's a big part of it and you know
and i always say like i i thank my
parents for [ __ ] being so like just
supportive and playing with me all the
time because i feel like you know they
love me that i've made me love myself
i'm confident who i am as a person
because i remember just walking around i
love your parents man they're so great
i just remember in elementary school
walking around and um the uh mr perez
the janitor he came up to me when i was
in the bathroom one time like after like
washing my hands and he was like hey you
you walked like a like a big man nice
that's like and this is like elementary
school bro and i was like
you missed a spot on the floor
thanks man
like the help's not supposed to talk to
the students i was like excuse me sir
you speak english
yeah i think what a lot of people when
they talk about like leagues and stuff
it's they probably find themselves ugly
both
like from a or alpha and beta type from
a visual and emotional standpoint yeah
because i think when
you're not able to express who you are
on the inside which makes up more of you
than you're outside in my opinion
then you're limited to your physical
attributes
so when you're limited to your physical
attributes then you're like
wait so how am i supposed to get that
chick she's way out of my league but if
you can that's how we worked out because
you were focused on the insights because
your outsides are just not
so yeah like when when people are able
to express their insights like you know
when you're funny you also got a great
personality i want to hang out with this
person right right you know because
people like if you're limited to the
outside i don't know anyone that's like
man i can't wait to hang out with
someone that's just 5 11 today
so you got to get that stuff on the
outside without saying it like you know
when you're writing a script you show
don't tell you go hey i'm really funny
just got to know me right it's like
that's really weird too
yeah i'm not a beaver trapper trust me
i'm a good guy i'm a guy i swear i'm a
great guy that's [ __ ] weird
it's hard i wouldn't even know what to
say because i'm a chick you know like
i've never had to been put in that
situation to like
have to like put my
best foot forward in order to like
uh impress i don't know if that's the
right word or see if someone is like i
want to
attract them to me
that's tough yeah i mean
you know at the end of the day i feel
like
if you can get
flirty jokes down to a science man you
can accomplish so much like me and rick
always
uh credit
uh like being able to
joke flirtatiously because also if
you're too jokey then there's a risk of
like friend zone or whatever yeah yeah
um but i feel like i was i always um
do the whole me and rick are big on the
whole um i'm just i'm just i'm just
playing unless you're down situation it
feels like that yeah yeah so we do a lot
of like um you know for girls like we'd
be interested in and i don't even know
how we both kind of both acquired this
this style of flirting yeah but we just
we both probably were trying to hit on a
chick and hurt each other and then went
like
yeah maybe and then we and then we
double teamed her yeah no
no but uh so it's just like a lot of
like um nah girl uh you know um
i would always
offer massages because i give really
good massages because i'm thai you know
even you even saying that already is so
flirty
yeah i know like i'm really good at
giving massages like if a girl hears
that we're like okay no but that's the
beauty of being funny because if a
regular guy's like hey you know i give
really good massages yeah don't touch me
crazy
then it's gross but if i'm like if a
girl's sore and i'm like well you know i
get really good massages if like if you
ever need like a booty rub or something
i'm just playing no but for real i give
good massages then it's like oh okay
he's [ __ ] around but wait do you give
massages for real and then the fact is i
give give booty massages for real and
then it's like next thing you know
she's naked she's naked and your dick is
out it's crazy
that's the secret
so learn to be funny yeah that's it yeah
i mean i yeah every one of the guys i
did it has always been pretty funny my
favorite massage pickup line is i always
go like this how's it go
that feels good you want to try that
and they usually say yes and they
massage them
wait massage yourself first yeah go
whoa
everyone wants to feel this
holy [ __ ] i'm amazing at this
yes oh god yes
please
so dumb
okay uh switching gears a little bit
because i know we talked about get uh
having a chick naked with your dick out
uh veda is so cute
nice turn right there
i warned you she's the cutest
i know you're picturing tim's dick out
and a naked chick and then it's like
vedas cute-ass face veda came from my
dick
and a chick being naked so it all makes
sense okay good
um how's new dead life
oh
i know
man
it's [ __ ] lit bro i love it yeah i
actually really really
love it so much okay what did you think
it was gonna be like
what is it really like and then what do
you love about it so i knew i was gonna
be like you know tired uh and i didn't
know what to expect because
i don't have any siblings i never had
any babies around me i had never changed
the diaper until veda i'd never even
really held a baby properly until veda
so uh you know part of me
was like a little nervous right um but
she you know she and i are the complete
opposite in the way we prepare for
things where she was like reading all
the books reading all the articles like
talking to people and i'm like and she
bought me books to read and i didn't
read them and i was like nice and i was
like ah i'll be fine i'll be fine up
until like a week before i was like oh
[ __ ] am i gonna know what to do you know
what i'm saying and i read a little bit
of one of the books but
but i still feel like you know it didn't
really do anything for me but
um and i didn't think books did anything
right i didn't really do them yeah you
read some right or no no
i tried and i was like yeah exactly
uh well because whatever i read i was
like okay i kind of already figured this
much oh i see and i don't know if it's
because i probably may have grown up
with i mean i didn't have little kids
but whatever yeah well
so i just i didn't know what exactly to
expect
and but i just knew i was gonna enjoy it
because i like
um
little kid [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like i like i watch disney movies just
as a grown man by myself right
and uh
and that's how you pick hot babes up
dude you say [ __ ] like that out loud and
not give a [ __ ] i guess so
secure with himself you know and um but
once
once we had veda i mean for sure of
course you know uh we're like every once
in a while we're like googling [ __ ] like
oh this was happening with my baby you
know right but um
i think it just it you don't i didn't
expect it to come so naturally like it
just it feels almost like
um
like i'm supposed to be doing this right
and i always tell people i knew i would
have fun but i didn't know it was gonna
be this fun like i genuinely like really
enjoy it that's awesome yeah man it's
dope and i think it's the difference
between and also we were we were really
we were ready you know i'm saying this
was something we wanted to do you
planned it yeah i think it's different
for like when you're like maybe way
younger and like it wasn't planned okay
then it's almost like oh [ __ ] right but
for us we were planned and we were grown
and um you lived life and we lived life
we have no regrets and we're ready for
it and um and so it's like i just man
i'm just it's so fun so when you
imagined it before she arrived
yeah uh what did you imagine it was be
like like crying babies dirty house
everywhere or like not like a bunch of
fun vacations like what was the
perception i mean i definitely you know
just kind of like you know i guess what
you saw on tv you know lots of crying
lots of diapers i thought i would get
like
peed and pooped on i mean i i did
boys tend to do the peeing
yeah because it shoots out yeah or the
only time vedas really peed on me is um
i was holding her before a bath and
where and then and then it was all just
oh
she's pissing
me
and there was only one time where i was
like it was so funny because like
i was changing her diaper and she left
the room to go get something and she
said she was literally in the next room
thinking oh man it's so great that i can
just leave tim
with the baby and and then then all of a
sudden i was changing the diaper and
then she started like she started
[ __ ] everywhere and i was like oh
she's [ __ ] and i tried to change i
was trying to lift her leg but then her
leg like dropped into the [ __ ] i was
like oh her foot fell in the [ __ ] and
then she started peeing too like oh my
god
and everything was like happening at
once
oh [ __ ]
that's so funny she's like uh finally a
moment to myself no yeah then and then
i'm like screaming in the other room
did you have any pets
no not even a pig what the [ __ ] yeah he
had like no training wheels no bam i'm a
dad now yeah maybe like a small fish
that died
so even at a pet owner you suck yeah
uh how was changing the first diaper
because you're not equipped so when i
first had to change taika's diaper yeah
like i'm used to changing diapers but
not to the capacity in which i had to do
it with my own kid
um and and taika had balls right dick
word and i was like is this clean enough
are we good yeah
so i gotta do i definitely have to uh
well changing my first diaper was cool
like it wasn't as bad as i expected to
be honest like
uh you know those first few months don't
really they don't stink that much it was
it's not until the solid foods right
where the [ __ ] gets like not ever that
bad oh man i don't know man
yeah like cause everyone was like yo
just wait till that she starts eating
solids then this [ __ ] is crazy
no man let me tell you something do you
like your [ __ ] smell though cause that's
different i don't really like my smell
either but like when when we started
feeding her real food like fruits and a
little bit of protein here and there
yeah gave her the protein her [ __ ]
smelled like grown man shits i was like
i opened this diaper and i felt like i
had it was like a homeless man had just
[ __ ] into my hand like it was like so
stinky because it doesn't have the
effect of a toilet where the dookie goes
in the water and then it all gets cut
it's just there yeah
and um but for the first few months
wasn't too bad
and but i did have to get used to uh i
was like oh [ __ ] i need to wipe poop out
of a cooch right now yeah and i
definitely had never done that before i
definitely don't know how to do that
yeah right it's so it's different and um
i'll shout i mean we could practice hell
yeah damn
hot
no
that was your idea you weirdo i know i
was hoping both of you guys would be
like [ __ ]
you guys flipped it on me real fast i
wasn't prepared
oh but yeah i um so i got to get used to
getting her clean you know what i'm
saying um
just uh and uh yeah it's fun yeah uh
okay so that's
that was your expectations and then it
turned out um and then what was what has
been like the most
i swear i could talk about kids all day
but what has been like the most like
rewarding part of it
the most rewarding part i mean look just
um just knowing that you're i mean y'all
know you have a child um but just know
but just knowing that like i'm
helping mold this little person is so
like crazy right it's like it blows my
mind and the fact that she's
like everything is so new to me
and it's like the smallest thing is like
whoa
so like even you know like the first
smile and the first because you know for
the first few months they don't they
don't smile at all yeah and i did not
know it would take so long for her to
smile so i'm over here trying to be like
[ __ ] entertaining and [ __ ] and she's
just like man
and then so when she finally like i'm
losing it after chia
just unbothered right so but the first
time she finally let out a little giggle
i was like yes and now she actually like
you know she smiles and she's like
oh it's so lit i love it
and um
yeah man it's just it's it's it's really
just um
you know it's it sounds so cliche to say
but it's like you know you look into
their eyes and it's like oh this i
created this this
you just feel like them like staring at
you so like adoringly like wow this is
i'm all they have in life you know yeah
it's cool it's a beautiful feeling like
there's times where i'm like lecturing
him or like disciplining him because he
did something bad right yeah of course
and then i look into his eyes
i'm like my phone is trying to melt me
right now
trying to be all stars [ __ ] melted me
there's times where he's scolding him
and then like is like doing this thing
oh and he's all sad he's like [ __ ]
mean because he really feels bad you
know kids are so expressive so he's like
doing that thing and then bart he'll
just start cracking up because he thinks
he's so cute and then and then ty is so
confused yeah he's like why are you
laughing papa why
he goes i'm not laughing i'm trying to
tell you that you made the wrong choice
cause papa's not funny
i'm gonna have to leave that to chia i
don't think i can do it
yeah
it's hard
it's hard but i feel like girls are
different
like um
taika we take him to bjj and like it's a
guy and girl class and all the
instructors will be like girls they just
catch on and they like follow direction
and they're they're in their head their
heads in the game boys are like they're
innately a little bit more rebellious
yes yeah so you should be fine
not even a set not even like trying to
rebel yeah but like they're just
naturally like coloring out of the lines
like that's the like girls it's like
okay you're gonna play in the circle and
then guys are already stepping out
they're doing you know just naturally
doing it i'm gonna have to
reprimand her about something at some
point and uh yeah you're gonna be like
you daddy
stop like stop hugging daddy so much oh
no
that's cool man i need to talk to your
parents i need to pick their brain on
how like they were able to create
such a happy only child
like sometimes i like now that i'm a mom
and you're sitting here i'm like taika
because we're both only children's i'm
the only child too i know but you're the
dad but i'm here
aren't i or no no you you have
somewhat of a turbulent relationship
with your parents i know but i think the
product is pretty happy and optimistic
yeah
i'm i'm picking your brain too but i'm
saying i want to pick his parents brain
his parents is awesome yeah i think at
the end of the day just like you know
support and love and attention and uh
but that means so many different things
you know different people true i think
the basic way of it though like you know
like in this day and age like there's a
big focus on love language yeah and i
think in our generation i think our
parents
uh focused on their love language so for
them they're like i didn't really have
well it's hard i don't have food to eat
right so it's like what do you mean i
don't love you i [ __ ] buy you rice
every day right right right no but
that's not my love language and i think
being able to express it in the love
language of the recipient is important
yeah i think the fact that you guys just
play with him so much is is doing so
much you feel me because like literally
one of my like a random memory i just
have of my dad and i was like probably
six years old five six years old is like
um
making like pillow forts and throwing
socks at each other like
bombs
and i just remember you know being an
only child you know your imagination is
always kind of going crazy and they
would always like play with me and like
and humor my
sense of like imagination and like weird
[ __ ] it was never like oh this is weird
it's like it's it was like feeding back
with me and like and making me know that
i wasn't strange for wanting to like
play this way or do these things you
know
i don't like it when they flip the rules
on you though like people be like the
floor is lava the floor is lava oh shoot
okay i'm on the chair and he goes
he starts walking on it like what are
you doing you're burning he goes i just
made it all ice
i want cheaters
[Laughter]
okay
next question and uh okay uh first
moment that you realized and this is in
quotes uh this is the leap i'm making
for my career
um
um
i feel like you've always had career in
mind but you did drop out of college
that must have been a huge one that that
was definitely a a huge uh you know a
moment why i felt like i made a real
decision towards
my career right um
because i was
in college
and the youtube stuff started picking up
and that's where i was doing more like
live events and stuff like that and uh
and i remember thinking
i can try and do both right like i'm
just gonna
take my classes part time and then i'll
just balance it out with these shows or
whatever whatever and then i started uh
and then i'd always end up dropping all
my classes i would have like one class a
semester and then i ended up just doing
that for like
years i was in college like i was in
college for like six years before i
dropped out because you know i i want to
say the youtube [ __ ] started picking up
around
my i mean i was like i don't know i was
like i was in college for a few years
already right and then i was like okay i
can still do this so then i'll just drop
all my classes have like one class a
semester one or two classes and then i
was like man all right i need to [ __ ]
pick something you know like i'm
bullshitting over here and i'm
bullshitting over here and i was like
and then an opportunity came up to do a
show in australia and i was like never
been in australia before this is lit i
can always go back to school next
semester yeah took a semester off went
to australia had a blast and then um
another like but then as a result more
opportunities were popping up so i took
another semester off you know and then i
took the year off and then i took two
years off and then i just never went
back two years were you like i'll
probably go back no well at two years i
think it costs a long beach once you
take two years off you you can't just
you can't just pick it up again right
and um that's what when i was like when
i when i took that second year off i
knew i was making the decision to not go
back so what about like financially did
you were you like in a place you're like
okay this is clearly
school is holding me back from like
getting more financial stability um not
not yet because there wasn't any money
in youtube yet you know when i when i
was first on youtube there was like no
money at all like i remember my first
brand deal was like for 500 bucks and i
was like yes
yeah this is lit right
and then i remember getting a free
toothbrush i'm like
thank you vanity planet this is awesome
damn shutting them out for free
and then actually the um and then i was
working at california peachy kitchen
pizza kitchen still and then um oh i
think i remember this story yeah and
then i got i got and i got fired but uh
it was because of a youtube video right
well it was got some tweets some tweets
oh yeah i tweeted do you wanna hear that
story of course you know that story
already no tell me [ __ ] it i'll tell you
again um
so i was working california pizza
kitchen and
this was before twitter was as like as i
didn't think it was as big right but
we were getting
new uniforms and i liked our uniform so
i tweeted at their twitter at california
pizza kitchen i was like
black button-ups are the lamest [ __ ]
ever and then someone dm'd me from cbk
and was like thank you for your opinion
on our new uniforms which store you work
at and i was like oh [ __ ]
how did they know that you worked at a
store um because they hadn't launched
the new uniforms yet
so
with story workouts like oh [ __ ] deleted
my tweet
and then um but and on my twitter there
was only a link to my youtube and on
youtube it said i was from long beach
so
damn they did all that investigation so
someone from cpk
called up the general manager of the
long beach area cpks and we're like do
you know this kid
and she was like yeah that's tim and
they're like well you gotta fire him
because of
because of that and because there was
something in the handbook that said
you're not allowed to publicly bad mouth
the company in any way
and there was another tweet where i said
[ __ ] cpk no no i love cbk we love you
hi cpk and there was a sponsor another
cauliflower crust
oh it's so good it's really good and
there's another tweet that said like
time to go to work at california skeeza
kitchen and they didn't like that
um do you have like a whole list there's
a couple tweets yeah yeah so they fired
me okay that was deserved bro
but actually did you even like working
there no it was fun i didn't mind i like
being a server sometimes it was fun to
talk to people and [ __ ] um and i love
the food
and there was actually but my name pops
up in articles sometimes because
there's actually i guess like the way
freedom of speech works technically now
is they would not have been able to fire
me back then if
something if i forget but yeah so i say
all that to say
the same week i got fired from
california pizza kitchen i won a youtube
contest for like 15 g's
and that was like the most amount of
money i'd ever had at once and that i
took that as like a sign from like god
and the universe be like okay i'm on the
right path i can now not work and just
crank out these youtube videos and then
that was like my last like you know
quote unquote real job you know dang
that's a sign
and you were living at home right yeah
yeah and you had like full freedom at
home mm-hmm
damn lit super
damn that was really nice okay i've been
wanting to know this too what's the
reason what's the reason behind veda's
name or i think they mean meaning
oh
okay are you ready for this i think so
why
okay well it's dangerous all right
so crisscross applesauce
crisscross applesauce
okay
now this is this is this is gonna it's
gonna be crazy okay just don't make it
scary is it scary
a little bit oh
no i don't wanna hear it no okay no i'll
just tell you you ready it's not scary
it's not scary okay good
um
it's from the movie my girl she loves
that movie that's it
the movie my girl she loves that movie
and the main girl in my girl her name is
vader that's it okay yeah
that's like taika's name it's like a
white yeah yeah it's a dope that's it
yeah and then we found out it it's like
exists in 30 different languages a word
like
catholics japanese maori whatever we're
like
cool that's his name yeah and
in like ancient like old sanskrit veda
means like wisdom and knowledge wow
uh were there any of the runner-ups we
have like a list
you want to give those up because you're
having other babies yeah okay got it
uh we had so taika was um so we were
like literally
we we had given uh no not yet i think it
was a week he was about to be born um we
were still considering what was it
i think it was either maximus or maxwell
um there's two max ones yes it was
either maximus
or taika and and then i was like [ __ ]
man like what if he's like not like a
maximus right like the pressure i mean
you know that's a big name to live up to
i feel that yeah like what if he's like
a shy timid boy and now he's a [ __ ]
maximus yeah like that's [ __ ] up to
put that on him
and we're like [ __ ] man what do we do
like maximus come here
and then my dad uh my dad had already
passed at this point um so
i wanted to name him something like my
dad like something representing my dad
but my brother
taika is like what grandson number one
two three
four five so he's a fifth one now
uh so all the variations of my dad's
names were all gone ah uh so then
is that like a
latino thing
what to like get a variation of the last
name no it was a me thing oh cool yeah
um so his his name is octavio um and
they had alt and we would call him ector
so
octavio
uh so we came with octavius okay and we
were like should we name them octavius
we're like [ __ ] what same thing like
there's like these big [ __ ] strong
names yeah so we just ended up putting
that in his middle name oh taika
octavius yeah damn that's tight it
sounds pretty cool i think so i think we
[ __ ] smashed it yeah does vita have a
middle name no
oh no because i also don't have a middle
name oh neither does he yeah that's uh
that's it for me i was like that's your
call then i don't know i don't even know
what they're for
it's it's for when people go do you have
a middle name and you go no yeah what
were they for before
i'm sure it has something to do with i
don't know property land or true i don't
know man who knows it probably looks
good when you like monogram your pajamas
yes
yeah maybe it's like the longer your
name was or the more names you had the
more status it was like like in game of
thrones you know like uh uh
uh like every time daenerys shows up
they gotta like the name yeah
starborn of the yeah you know breaker of
chains yeah
dude my name is jovanna antoinette
courinho wow as a [ __ ] kid i can
remember the [ __ ] day where i was
trying out it's almost thai yeah
yeah i had to writing it i remember
studying to remember how to spell
chantharangsu for sure yeah even the
middle name antoinette was easy it was
rough
bart
all right
well okay wait wait okay this is the
last one because it's so dumb okay but i
have to ask it
even though i don't want to
okay if bart and geo remake again black
and yellow would you rap with them
oh god
uh yeah
that's my favorite thing you guys have
ever done used to be the happiest guy
ever dude maybe for like i don't know
after something maybe for like our 20
years some [ __ ] that's so funny oh this
[ __ ] i love it yellow black yellow like
a yellow i love it but i feel like your
swag would be so much more on point for
the remake
why because you said you said you felt
so awkward in the first one yeah man i
could have sworn in my head
i was [ __ ] going in
i feel like now you know you've done
more like parodies and [ __ ] you've done
a little more acting like you might be a
little more confident on camera yeah
yeah it might be better yeah but i don't
think you're like you're gonna like it
i'll love it oh because you're better
yeah yeah no keep it awkward you're
right
dude you and chia will randomly just
[ __ ] with me and send me texts you guys
suck and i love it
all right man that's it those i mean
there's a ton of [ __ ] questions so
many people wanted us so much about you
which i think is super dope um but yeah
that's all the time we have they're just
nosy i love it i love it because i mean
a lot of these questions i wanted to
know too
so thank you this was fun thanks for
having me guys as always thanks for
having me in your lovely home thank you
thanks for following this is not our
home this is i mean your dope studio
with the fireplace plans books sick
shelf
it's totally not at home just kidding
thanks for feeding us barbecue after
this yeah yeah we're gonna eat barbecue
now um but thank you for tuning in
thank you so much thank you tim like
always we love you thank you bart for
roasting all the time i love you too
you speak facts yeah all right whatever
uh and catch you guys next time
bye